[Música]
Bienvenidos a directo cop 27 de este
espacio especial en France 24 en el que
profundizaremos en los temas que se
discuten en la conferencia climática de
Naciones Unidas que se lleva a cabo
hasta el próximo 18 de noviembre en la
ciudad egipcia de charmel change esta ha
sido la primera jornada de discusiones
de alto nivel y de pronunciamientos de
jefes de estado y de gobierno entre los
mensajes más destacados estuvieron el
del secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez quien aseguró que las opciones
son trabajar juntos para reducir las
emisiones contaminantes o condenar a las
generaciones futuras a una catástrofe
climática también el del presidente de
Francia Manuel macón quien dijo que los
acuerdos climáticos logrados hasta el
momento no pueden ser sacrificados en el
contexto de la guerra en Ucrania a esta
hora conectamos con Marina Colorado
enviada especial de France 24 a esta
cita Marina usted se encuentra en el
corazón de esta Cumbre hemos visto El
eco de estos pronunciamientos de los
países desarrollados Pero cuál ha sido
finalmente el mensaje de las Naciones en
desarrollo las principales Víctimas de
la crisis climática
pues como era de esperar en esta copa
africana El primer día te tenía una
fuerte presencia de los líderes de los
países del continente con una demanda
común solidaridad climática estos países
están hartos de ver como los países más
industrializados no hacen más que hacer
promesas vacías y no cumplen con los
compromisos adquiridos uno de los
mensajes más potentes del día de hoy fue
el de la primera ministra de Barbados
Mia motley Que criticaba cómo era
posible que las grandes empresas
productoras de petróleo y de gas que han
recibido en los últimos tres meses más
de 200 mil millones de dólares en
beneficios no se dignen a entregar
aunque sea 10 céntimos por cada dólar
para la lucha contra el cambio climático
esta falta de colaboración por parte de
los países y de las empresas más
contaminantes hace precisamente que los
países en vías de desarrollo tengan que
buscar alianzas entre sí para luchar y
adaptarse a los efectos del el
calentamiento global y del cambio
climático precisamente nuestra compañera
María Clara Clara María Clara calle
también enviada especial a sharkmel say
entrevistó al ministro de medio ambiente
y de recursos naturales de República
Dominicana al respecto
ministros Gracias por estar con nosotros
aquí en France 24 los países
Centroamericanos antes de venir aquí a
la con 27 firmaron una declaratoria que
hablaba del enfoque Regional de la
adaptación y el financiamiento cuéntenos
En qué consiste esta declaratoria y Por
qué es importante hablar de adaptación
en los países del Caribe sí los países
centroamericanos y la República
Dominicana que está en el Caribe Mira la
gran dificultad que tenemos nuestros
países pequeños
es que no son no tenemos una
responsabilidad directa sobre los gases
efectos invernaderos
en nuestra participación por ejemplo el
caso de República Dominicana es en el
0.008%. Ahora sí somos muy impactados
por el tema del cambio climático estamos
en la trayectoria de Los huracanes y nos
afecta considerablemente al país de
hecho un país como República Dominicana
tiene un estado en una situación de
extrema vulnerabilidad por su condición
de La Isla No ahora bien en esto
obviamente tenemos que cumplir con la
mitigación que es
aumentar nuestro compromiso de reducción
de gases efecto invernaderos y tenemos
que darle el ejemplo pero también como
contraparte en nuestra preocupación
número uno está en la adaptación la
adaptación no es una opción es una
obligación entonces para eso necesitamos
recursos entonces aquí hay un ajedrez
complicado en el sentido de que bueno
vamos a fortalecer la mitigación no
Porque necesitamos los países
desarrollados un apoyo en el de
financiamiento un financiamiento blando
por supuesto para poder enfrentar el
problema de la adaptación que es nuestro
principal desafío al ser países en
extrema situación de vulnerabilidad
bueno así recibimos estas señales
agradecemos a Marina Colorado y María
Clara calle enviados especiales de
France 24 y a ustedes por su sintonía
continúen con nuestra programación
[Música]